votre petite pique la sueur des libéraux
j'habite au métro couronnes vous avez
déjà a déjà commencé par ramasser comme
me dire j'adore noir non métro couronnes
oui mais vous vous voyez un peu
l'environnement du métro couronnes nommé
hier alors pour ne pas décider pour les
téléspectateurs laisse le parisien
centre belleville et ménilmontant
couronne s'il ya une très fameuse
mosquée j'habite à 50 mètres de cette
mosquée dont il m'arrive vous a dit
m'arrive de croiser régaler aux arabes
et même quelques musulmans
donc ne dit pas des gens comme moi vous
voulez vous les voyez comment ils vont
vous livrer une pizza parce que ce que
vous dites effectivement vous avez vous
pratiqué très content mais on avait
commencé par là donc moi pour me dire un
peuple japonais je mange des néologismes
non elle veut dire au revoir non c'est
vous qui les japonais il avait dit voilà
c'est vous qui avez commencé à la cour
vous avez dit en fait vous ne voyez des
arabes quand il voue énormément
désignant des gens comme moi il s'avère
que je vois tout le monde alors moi déjà
je vois à travers vous juste le la la
ils ont craint conséquent n'importe
quand je vous jure mais plutôt prendre à
la maison vous allez très surpris en
colo je vends bien regarder la question
mais je vous donne une réponse comme
talent vous avez dit franchement moi
j'ai mes mots parce que moi dans son
racisme il est de qualité
vous êtes leader price vous n'êtes même
pas bon et vous avez su même pas l'idée
que de dire et de s'établir à métro
couronnes rupture non mais attendez vous
avez quoi de l'offre qui se battent en
duel à côté d'un foyer malia ça y est
vous connaissez les maliens ne sait pas
bien ce nom mais arrêtez de
condescendants 10 ans j'habite à
couronne
non mais c'est tout ne parlez pas de des
libéraux des trucs comme ça c'est pas de
votre niveau même vous vous êtes au
dessus de ça c'est dire là il s'avère
que moi ma femme ne fait pas manger je
commence ou leur délivreront et j'ai pas
de problème avec